اما منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي جون كيربي فقال ان
الرئيس جو بايدن بحث مع امير قطر الشيخ
تميم بن حمد ال ثاني والرئيس المصري عبد
الفتاح السيسي اخر التطورات في اسرائيل
وقطاع غزه بما في ذلك الجهود الجاريه
لاطلاق سراح الرهائن في
القطاع
تحدث الرئيس بايدن مع امير قطر الشيخ تميم
بن حمد ال ثاني والرئيس المصري لبحث اخر
التطورات في اسرائيل وغزه بما في ذلك
جهودنا لتامين اطلاق سراح جميع الرهائن
الذين تحتجزهم حماس نواصل بذل كل ما في
وسعنا لتسهيل التوصل لاتفاق اخر بشانه
منسق شؤون الشرق الاوسط بريت ماكغورك يعود
لواشنطن بعد اجراء سلسله جيده من
المحادثات مع نظراء بالمنطقه والتي شملت
بالتاكيد المسؤولين القطريين نحن متفائلون
بشان التقدم لكنني لا اتوقع اي تطورات
وشيكه وبالتالي لن اخوض في تفاصيل
المفاوضات او اتكه بالنتائج
المحتمله